[Music]
the first episode of moon night is out
and it did not disappoint so here in
this video we will have a bit of a
non-spoiler review about the plot of the
episode and discuss on two monsters that
was seen in it
as we have already seen these in the
trailers it won't be much of a spoiler
anyway but for those who are sensitive
then watch this video only after seeing
the entire first episode so subscribe if
you haven't already
for content just like this as we have
seen that many viewers are not actually
subscribed to our channel as yet anyway
let's get to it
let's talk a little bit on moon knight
so here we have steven grant a
mild-mannered museum gift shop employee
who is troubled by blackouts and
flashbacks of a past life he leads a
miserable and lonely existence believing
that he sleep walks and he ties one of
his legs to a pose while sleeping to
prevent him from drifting off he has no
awareness of his other identities
especially one called mark spectre
and he believes the visions are caused
by a mental disorder he keeps on
blacking out from one
spot to another in the show showing that
whenever the other personality takes
over steven loses all grip on reality
and does not remember anything at all in
one of those visions he gets transported
to a village in the swiss alps and
encounters a god leader called arthur
harrow who seems to have magical powers
and runs his own religious cult
the other hymn mark specter takes over
whenever imminent danger is at hand it
is later in the episode that we see him
transform into the actual moon night
so now after that brief just on the show
we will look into
that horrific bird slash ghost monster
that appeared when he found out about
his other personality
well this creepy scp-looking monster is
actually the egyptian god god konchu
it is not clear if this god is part of
the original init
the egyptian pantheon of gods but he is
a very powerful deity and a source of
power for the moon knight konchu is the
nocturnal god of the moon the god of
vengeance and shepherd of the lost he
was described as the greatest god of the
great gods not being able to enter the
earthly plane
so throughout history he would pick a
champion who would work as an avatar of
him and be guided by his will and the
lone warrior would be called the moon
knight
so let's describe a bit on the design
and appearance of konchu in the mcu and
what are his powers
konchu appears in the show as a tall
humanoid being around seven to eight
feet tall dressed in white cloth that
are wrapped around his body like that of
a mummy he is slim and lean and holds a
scepter which bears a large crescent
moon at the top
the most peculiar look is the raven
skull that is supposedly his head and
seems like an scp monster to me anyway
konchu is a god with tremendous powers
able to live hundreds of tons
very high endurance and durability a
powerful regenerative healing factor and
magic manipulation as well as very
enhanced hand-to-hand combat skills
all these powers are transferred to the
moon knight avatar of him from his other
pocket dimension called the celestial
heliopolis where he and the other gods
reside
so enough about konchu and let's look at
the next monster we saw on the show the
wolf-like monster that appeared near the
end of the episode and was killed
brutally by steven slash mark
moon knight when he transformed into the
avatar so what is it and what are its
powers
marvel cinematic universe fans studied
the first trailer of the show after it
was released and theorized that it was
the werewolf by night and it would
appear so while moon knight does have a
wolf-like creature in its first episode
it's nothing like werewolf by night
instead it's something considerably more
terrible it looks like a werewolf but
really it isn't one so what in the world
is it
anyway so late in the episode grant
stephen graham is attacked by a beast
that resembles an egyptian jackal
brought to life by arthur harrow who
seeks to scarab an egyptian artifact
that holds a certain kind of power the
creature is tall ferocious and unlike
anything the mcu has ever seen before
and it is only defeated after grand
relinquishes control of his body to
another identity that unleashes the
power of the moon knight
this creature of the wolf-like creature
was maybe a death dog something that
looked like jackals and were lesser
deities that acted as guides in the
afterlife
some theorized that it was an avatar of
anubis himself or a race created by
anubis that can be summoned to drag
souls into the afterlife kinda like
those from the movie the moment returns
you know that jackal army of anubis that
helps the rock this creature looked very
close to them and also to anubis from
the movie gods of egypt so it's not a
werewolf by night but an egyptian death
dog
anyway that's it with that we come to
the end of it so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family but most
of all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel
till the next one take care fam